[Musica]
una [ __ ] tutti ragazzi ne vedo che
sono video martello simulator 2017
grazie grazie e ho comprato un
climatizzatore portatile quindi melo
sono piazzati in camera adesso quando
questa non ce miss patricia in faccia
non ho più caldo unico problema è che mi
caga va addosso hanno paura che facesse
troppo rumore no ma che cazzo se ne
frega se tanto c'è quello che sbatte
anche sua madre sul soffitto grazie 0 le
ragazze lassù spins punto rios prinzio
io questa roba da te la devi smettere
hanno unito svizzeri oe ifigest filler
per fare adesso io vorrei fare una
partita sta roba che mondo per aversi
ieri un mondo meraviglioso se la gente
non mi trapana singoloni quando agli
ultrà però solo il fatto che esiste un
gioco che l'unione tra slither io e
figisc binner per me vale la vita da
diventare grosso però il viatico ac
c'ero anche io non lo faccio io la gente
non sono anche diversi casi lo chiamo io
continua a girare a quello perché gira
di più perché punti ai cugini non ho
capito ora vado a quanto gira stato chi
gira di più ammazza penso di sì non ho
idea tipo io adesso mi giro di vite in
questo quadro ammazzo sottocosto pam per
fermi tias dio adesso arrivo su roteando
arrivo previsto gioco si ammazza girando
più degli altri geniale ciao rai meglio
appena ammazzato material mazzocchi no
no no porco quello che martella come non
numerato al cup come ho fatto a perdere
[ __ ] caso la città paga ma sei tu
sai ma ci avrai la madre butta un po
come quello che martella su allora che
siamo 75 nel server devo arrivare tra i
primi dieci mesi sbatto le balle la
tattica giusta ma gli us molecola tua
famiglia la tattica giusta ragazzi per
arrivare intoppo è quella di raccogliere
un sacco di punti inizierà ad arrivare
un po più avanti perché sono accento
primo arrivare almeno a 300
ma quanto sei ricco giorni raccogliamo
un po di punti raga almeno ad arrivare a
300 orca vacca dei fatti che dovete
farvi cazzi vostri amici gente che sta
small e colato dio santo cura dal primo
era il primo in classifica 22.000 punti
ma ce l'hai una vita una ragazza forse
no porca vacca se mismo no no no da hera
che palle non è giusto era un'ora vicino
a casa ma stai lontano da via spiga nel
frattempo tipo col martello si è cagato
addosso ha smesso di martellare grazie
zio perché io parlo parlo a fare io
perché occorrono che potevo stare zitto
marcava che il suo creato devi avere i
dati ragazzo cosa vuoi da me perché
cerca intanto di uccidermi questo poi il
problema questi si fanno la guerra
se si fa lavora iso cota rica vacchiano
mister non mi toccare ma che cazzo c'è
una stellare così da vaticano sta
spendendo il quadro di gesù cristo ma
che il grosso sto quadro che sta
apprendendo anche 333 ti ammazzo ti
ammazzo muovono come polis maker avete
male ma fatto non ho toccato loro
toccato parquet ma ho persi punti o
persino quando becco la gente la gente
perde punti e velluti li posso prendere
io ecco questo è più o meno il modo di
vincere perché io ragazzi vado più vado
avanti più becco gente che sta in
classifica come è possibile come facesse
così sfigato perfetto tv togliere zio
perfetto la strage l'altra triple kill
tributi quadra kill ma d'oro nella 30 km
da talca libia no no no io non mi devo
pagare il caso facendo le stragi stato
sto facendo è stata ci sto perdendo
punti fantastico io ammazzo gente perde
punti come è possibile infatti fuori 5
però non devono dei dovrei ammazzare
così tanti perché dovere tempo di
recuperare i punti che perdo dai raga
che ci arriviamo da almeno dieci vivo
rientrare i casi harley quinn modo ma se
avete un altro cosplay di sta roba pieni
quasi avviene quasi ai linguaggi andati
e che scappi l'iniqua i ricavi di coda
tranquilla ti faccia niente
okaka non fate domande grande prendo io
prendo io tranquillo tranquillo faccio
io
anzi tutti pacchetto anche un po ci stai
ora molto sto girando veloce quanto sto
girando veloce parte la vittoria tira il
cazzo 300 punti sono più forte io le
tettoie vi dalle palle tutti
la perché ha perso punti ma cosa hanno
capito a noa noa zio dai che tu e
cognomi ha ucciso non mi ha ucciso per
pochissimo non mi ha ucciso dio
ok raga posso iniziare a far fuori
quelli più scarsi perché bisogna
prendere punti se magari la turchia
schifosa nomica galca perché lì calgary
il cazzone e turchia di merda su c'è
lega brutte
porca vacca cosa ho fatto grande sono
tornato a 400 punti ragazzi perché quel
pirla l'immediato al tizio non mi devi
toccare mi fai schifo odio la gente ecco
questo sono io quando entro in metro
così fatemi lontano tutti è un
puntualmente qualcuno ti viene addosso
proprio il m m simulator ragazzo turchia
maledetta loschi bat amore come i segway
creò aiutava va sempre lui becco ci
mancherebbe culo non ammazza prima o poi
ecco la cava con l'alta 1800 stati su
cemec acute 66 coyote per entrare in
classifica deve arrivare a mille ma voi
state ma avete le malattie voi marzo a
gesù decidono che devo giocare violento
perché ho capito che se sono tranquillo
non vado adesso la parte ci mette una
vita e non ho voglia di metterci una
vita anche perché tra cinque dieci
minuti arriva il sushi quindi ho bisogno
necessariamente di far fuori qualcuno
anzi calmiamoci di capire un attimo non
mi toccata a marzo la famiglia t'ammazzo
di capita ma sti strangolo nel sonno
seguiamo un tic enzo che mezzo tipo fa
vigenza tua sorella morta niente è uno
solo rispondano a destra non lo so
provarne la parola pubblici retto bene
lo so non capisco almeno respon aree non
capiamo il ciclo apple e vinci dei miei
visto
ragazzi li ho portati un gioco nuovo
siete contenti sono proprio contento di
giocare a questa roba non ho mai giocato
almeno qua mi chiama so come si gioca
nell'altro porca di una vacca o sono io
che sono scarso come la morte e la
casacca del porto da qualcuno va gioco
di me non so giocare malga questo cioè
hanno fatto tutto spin neri o spin ios
l'inter io non c'è tizio che mi martella
il soffitto io il rosso crepe al rosso
che ne parrozzo crepa si fuori verde
farlo per la v usati dall 80 per cento
della monetizzazione del video ti prego
e tanto sono 10 centesimi perché youtube
non pagavo incazzata e titan come ti
muore il cugino io vi giuro che questa è
l'ultima con questo questo che questa è
l'ultima volta è l'ultima volta che
gioco ad una roba che finisce punto io
l'ultima lui vorrebbe giocare una roba
mai più perché se potessi schiacciare i
testicoli con una martellata forte
perdonatemi sempre solito sono stato un
po irascibile però ho cercato di merda e
quando gioco di merda
ieri il bastone del martello infilerei
però io mi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa è
servito come non mi piace anche i vari
social community dane descrizione senza
vestiti scateni ci picchiavano prossimo
bella ragazzi
[Musica]